all right letting you know right out the
gate this video is brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build your online presence and run your
business gonna talk about that a little
later but first let's talk about
marvel's what if a series on disney plus
where i talked about the first episode
then didn't talk about any other
episodes and the reason for that is
every one of the marvel series i've
enjoyed in one way or another but at
about episode four or five
every time i get this feeling of like i
gotta do that video today
i kind of don't wanna feel obligated to
do that video on that episode of that
show today so i was like all right let's
just binge it at the end and i did and i
enjoyed the fact that i did it that way
so now in one video as villains say in
one fell swoop i talk about all of it
out the gate spoiler warning gonna get
spoilerish talking about this because
when i talk about shows sometimes i like
doing that this isn't gonna be a
play-by-play it's not gonna be a
deconstruction this is gonna be one of
those videos where it's like 78 things
you missed in every episode not just my
thoughts but it's gonna get a little
spoilerish now you know that and the
show ended up being exactly what it
seemed like it was going to be from the
pilot episode which is a series of short
stories it felt like a novel were the
novels made up of a series of short
stories that
that's what it is granted by the end
there is a thread that ties it all
together it's like oh okay so it was
actually leading up to this like the
t'challa episode where it's t'challa
star-lord not gonna lie
it hits ya chadwick boseman voices
t'challa in here you know you feel it
you're like oh dude
you forget that he's gone soothing
nature of a voice is a very strange
thing it's funny how a voice can make
you forget about the reality you live in
it's it was actually cool
forgetting about that and t'challa
wasn't just in that episode there were a
few episodes he was in but what i liked
most about what if is what you see in a
lot of these episodes where it's like
one change drastically changes the
effects of the entire universe or that
reality ian malcolm 101 and also a
philosophy that completely pre-dates ian
malcolm point is because t'challa was
star-lord now thanos didn't you know
he's like i'm not gonna snap everyone to
death i'm still gonna talk about it over
some drinks because t'challa was
star-lord thanos took a different route
then we see nebula when she's not just
completely messed up it's neat to see
these what-if curve balls these
hypotheticals thrown out there which i
guess aren't hypotheticals they're
realities in a different universe but
for the sake of the mcu unless they're
brought into the actual cinematic
universe they remain more or less
hypothetical we'll see when kang shows
up how much of this actually bleeds over
i don't know but episode three was
interesting for me because that's when i
started to see
the difference between old mcu and new
mcu in terms of the humor because in
episode three you had scenes from old
mcu you know hawkeye's up there and he
has a bow and arrow all right i can take
out thor or the guy going for the hammer
because we don't really know who he is
yet and they start making jokes about
thor's hair and how he smells like
lavender and i was like that dialogue
wasn't in the mcu
in that movie but here it is now
really showed the difference between old
mcu and new mcu and it
it irritated me
i don't know i'm a sucker for continuity
i guess i get it it's a different
universe but that's not why they did it
they did it so it would feel like the
mcu now and it just made me miss the mcu
of old where they took [ __ ] seriously
sometimes episode four was great where
doctor strange was like i need to save
rachel mcadam's life and he keeps going
back and trying to do it but he can't
it's not the first time i've seen it in
entertainment at all so doctor strange
is like i'm gonna steal life essence and
steal souls and eventually look like the
howling man from the twilight zone i
really like that episode it's like the
mcu again accidentally made one of the
more compelling mcu villains which in
terms of writing and production when
these things go into production i feel
like shang chi started production before
what if did which means they were like
hey we really like that villain arc of a
villain doing the wrong things for love
and that makes him a villain so we'll
just make doctor strange do that the
zombie episode you know my big takeaway
is with a zombie episode they have their
base suspended by spider-man's webbing
the webbing that dissolves in a couple
hours
not a smart plan regardless yeah marvel
zombies but this is one of those moments
where
what if the fun thing about what if is
you can just throw out really anything
you want you can do some really fun
creative things but you do still have to
make things within context and
characters so the fact that vision's
taking people and feeding them to wanda
to zombie wanda i was like would vision
do that i don't think you would do that
also marvel's really found a stride of
people doing the wrong things for love
here it's it's kind of like they're like
sweet that's a zone people like that
never deviate as much as i can say i
don't think vision would do that in
spider gwen the comic books matt murdock
was essentially the kingpin i thought
that was cool i didn't read enough of
the comic books to get to the point
where they might have elaborated as to
how and why that happened in his life
but i thought it was a neat thing so it
lends itself to comic books if this is a
comic book i suppose i wouldn't question
it too much i'd be like well obviously
something happened in the past but i
suppose when you're watching it in
motion you know whether it be animated
or live action or some odd reason in my
brain i'm like well i require a reason
so i suppose it would help me to
mentally keep it in the mindset of like
well it's it's a short story like a
comic book you can just roll with it i
mean same with hank pym hope died on a
mission for shield and hank pym snaps
and becomes the the bumblebee or
what's this yellow jacket so he's wiping
out the avengers you're seeing in his
eyes you're like dude you've gone mad
you're like crazy old man eyes hank pimp
i don't know it's just like his wife
gets lost in the quantum realm and he's
like yeah i'm sad but there's hope yet
i'll actually gear my daughter up at the
end of the movie to go out there and
possibly die his daughter dies on a
mission of shield he's like [ __ ] it i'm
the bumblebee [ __ ] the avengers start
with no loki was a cartoon it was one of
those episodes where i was like you
could have done anything thor without a
brother because they always got the
feeling that thor you know he was kind
of party mischievous thor and then he
had his arc of like hey
become better in the thor movie and then
he did and you could argue that having
loki as opposition made him step up and
be a better person but also having loki
as a brother made him not take things
seriously so he's like oh yeah i'm thor
i'm awesome hey who needs responsibility
so not having loki as a brother you
could have done anything and they were
like hey let's have dude bro party thor
why not and i feel like they were trying
to play up the whole comedic tone that
thor ragnarok brought to the thor
character essentially making thor in the
mcu the thor that was
in those what was it was a youtube show
or webisodes where he's like working out
and he's like that's a brain that's a
brain that's a brain like any novel of
short stories what if as some short
stories are just better than others that
one i was just like
i don't need to ever watch that one
again with the tony stark episode i was
most interested when it was like oh the
hero iron man never got made so tony
stark actually starts going the way of
villainy that was really compelling and
then killmonger kind of takes him out
and takes over and then killmonger does
exactly what killmonger
did in black panther bring the body of
claw and then become black panther and
all right there we go i was like i feel
like i've seen this before episode 89 is
where things start to get connected you
know those episodes work together as one
episode also it pulls back from the
other episodes like hey we gotta
assemble a team the guardians of the
multiverse but the what if is what if
ultron had one and
well no he didn't pick up the land and
then drop the land like a meteor no i
just set off a bunch of nukes probably a
better plan my one thought though is
when ultron's there he's in vision's
body you know he he has the vision body
and thanos walks through with all but
the mind stone and he goes fascinating
he just cuts him in half i was like
wait
i didn't think about that before could
vision have just done that if his
girlfriend wasn't trying to you know
break his head that has solved a lot of
problems there but it gets to the point
where ultron's like i've done it i've
succeeded i feel like i have no purpose
because of that does he start a family
no that would be ridiculous now he takes
on the watcher of the multiverse which
is the part of me is like why did you do
that could you see everything because
the watch was like oh i can't interfere
and i feel like all trying to be like
all right good talk have fun watching me
[ __ ] [ __ ] up because ultron engaged him
i guess he did interfere could thanos
sense the watchers and fight him since
he had all the stones i mean he didn't
he was like ah i'm just gonna snap and
garden regardless for the finale the
watcher goes back and pulls
the greatest team which definitely is
not the greatest game this isn't the
strongest team he could have gotten i
mean of all the multiverse this is the
best you got i i don't know i suppose
it's
what we had from the show you're telling
me dude bro thor is more efficient than
whatever dick bag thor might be out
there but maybe the watchers like kurt
russell from miracle looking for the
best players craig i'm looking for the
right ones you could always say that
where it's like oh the watcher knows
what's gonna happen he knew this was the
team that would get it done that's why
it's so hard to talk about this like
well wouldn't he because you're dealing
with this being that has that power but
in the end just looks like the writers
didn't want to go that route the writers
those are the real gods of the show i
suppose just me going through it that's
why i titled these things my thoughts
but in the end like what if was fine
like if it was a week-to-week thing
it would never consume my weeks like i'd
be like oh dude i can't wait until the
next episode of what if but you know
binging it all when it's all wrapped up
and just seeing these hypothetical short
stories were not hypothetical
actual realities among the multiverse
which i guess you could argue all
hypotheticals are i enjoyed it just fine
i mean obviously not enough for me to be
like yeah i definitely want to do
episode episode week to week videos on
it they do a good job with the voices
when you have the voices from the mcu
movies it's really cool when it's not
the voices it's generally speaking
pretty noticeable but they did a good
job like tony stark with the writing of
the character was actually impressed
with some of his quips i was like yeah
it does sound like tony stark those are
my thoughts on marvel's what if the
biggest hurdle marvel has to overcome
for me is the resolution i felt at the
end of the infinity zone end game was
literally my end game everything else
after that with marvel is well i enjoy
this fun extra but before we go once
again this video is brought to you by
squarespace squarespace sells over 200
top-level domains so you can find the
perfect name for your website buying a
domain from squarespace is simple with
no hidden fees you can present videos
from youtube vimeo and animoto on your
squarespace site and as always i dig the
fact that every design automatically
comes with a unique mobile experience
that matches the overall style of your
website i mean it's 2021 that mobile
experience integration is essential so
go to squarespace.com for your free
trial and when you're ready to build
that empire click the link below go to
squarespace.com jeremy john's get
yourself 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain using promo code
john's and thank you once again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it alright so marvel's
what if have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you